PROFESSOR: Today, we have to
discuss harmonic perturbations.
So we've done Fermi's golden
rule for constant transitions.
We saw transitions from a
discrete state to a continuum.
And by integrating
over the continuum,
we found a nice rule,
Fermi's golden rule,
that govern the transition
rate for this process.
So the only thing we
have to do different
now is consider the case
that the perturbation is not
just a step that gets
up and stays there,
but it has a
frequency dependence.
So that will bring a
couple of novel features.
But at the end of the
day, as we will see,
our Fermi's golden rule is
going to look pretty similar
to the original
Fermi's golden rule.
A nice application of
Fermi's golden rule
is the calculation of the
ionization rate for hydrogen,
in which you take
a hydrogen atom,
you put it in an electric
field or send a light wave,
and then suddenly the
electron and the hydrogen atom
from the ground state ionizes.
And we can compute already--
we have the technology
to compute the ionization rate.
That's a pretty
physical quantity.
And that will be an example
we'll develop today.
Those rates have
the funny situation
that the calculation
can be somewhat
involved and interesting.
And the answers, generally,
by the time you simplify them,
are pretty simple
and pretty nice.
So it's a good idea.
You have to have patience
with those calculations
to simplify it till the end,
and that's pretty instructive.
So we begin with
harmonic perturbations.
So we did constant
perturbations already.
So now harmonic perturbations.
So our situation is
that in which age H of t
is equal to a known
Hamiltonian plus delta H of t.
And this time, delta H
of t is conventionally
written as 2 H
prime cosine omega t
for some t between t0
and 0, and 0 otherwise.
All of us wonder why the 2 here.
One reason for it-- it's
all convention, of course.
You have your perturbation,
and what you call E H prime
or what you call 2 H
prime is your choice.
But this 2 has the
advantage that when
you describe the cosine
in terms of exponentials--
e to the i omega t plus e to the
minus i omega t-- the over 2,
it cancels this one.
And that makes Fermi's golden
rule, that will follow also
and will be valid for
these perturbations,
take exactly the
same form as it did
for the case of
constant perturbation.
So it's fairly convenient to
put that 2, and we'll put it in.
Some books don't, and then they
have different looking formulas
for Fermi golden rule
depending to which case you're
talking about.
Of course, when we mean that
this is the time dependence,
we are implying that H
prime is time independent.
Because the time
dependence is this one.
That's what we're
interested in considering.
Of course-- this has
been asked sometimes--
H prime can depend on all
kinds of other thing-- position
coordinates, some
other quantities.
But we're focusing on time
here, so we'll leave it there.
Moreover, for reasons
of convention,
just let's always thing
of omega as positive.
It wouldn't make a difference
if it would be negative here
with the cosine function, but
let's just set by convention
that omega is positive.
Finally, we're going
to do transitions again
from an initial
to a final state.
So we will consider
the case when
we go from an initial
state to a final state.
And therefore, we will
work in this language
with this constant
coefficients Cn's, these
coefficients that multiply
the states in psi tilde.
Psi tilde is equal to
Cn n of t, sum over n.
And these Cn's,
at time equals 0,
will be equal to delta ni,
which means that they are all 0
except when we're talking
about Ci at 0 is equal to 1
because we start with
an initial state.
We had a general formula for
the transition coefficient.
And Cm of 1 at time equal t--
or I'll put t0--
is equal to sum over n,
integral from 0 to t0 e
to the i omega mn t prime, delta
H mn of t prime over i h bar,
Cn at time equals 0, dt prime.
This was our general formula
for transition coefficients.
The Cm's is the coefficient
or the amplitude for the state
to be found in the m
eigenstate at time t0
to first order in
perturbation theory.
And it depends on
where you started on.
That's why the sum over n
here with initial states.
But this sum is going
to collapse because we
know we start with the state i.
So when we substitute
Cn equal to this,
the sum only works
when n is equal to i.
So we'll put for ni's.
And, of course, we're going to
also take for the final state
to be f.
So the formula now
reads Cf 1 at t0
is equal to integral from 0
to t0 e to the I omega f--
m was f-- i t prime.
And now the delta H. The delta
H is this whole quantity,
so we have to substitute it.
So 2 H prime is the only part
that has matrix elements.
The cosine omega t
is just a function.
So it's H prime fi cosine
omega t prime, and dt prime.
There's the i h bar.
So I think I got
everything right.
The sum collapsed.
mn is being replaced
by the right labels.
mn here, this is the expectation
value between m and n.
And that becomes
between f and i.
And it affects this
whole thing, but it just
ends up affecting the
Hamiltonian H prime here.
So I think we're OK.
We have everything there.
And Hfi, of course, doesn't
have time dependence.
So we said H prime has
no time dependence.
So that thing can go
out of the integral.
So this will go out.
And the integral is simple
because you have now
Hfi prime over i h bar.
And the 2, we leave
it for the cosine.
So we get two integrals.
t0 e to the i omega fi
plus omega t prime--
from the first exponential
in the cosine--
plus an e to the i omega
fi minus omega t prime--
from the second
exponential in cosine--
dt prime.
Well, that's very nice.
This is all doable.
The Hfi doesn't
give us any trouble.
It's a constant.
It's out of the integral.
It's all pretty nice and simple.
So we can do these
two integrals.
They're integrals
of exponentials,
so it's just an exponential
divided by those coefficients.
So I'll just do it and
evaluated it between t0 and 0.
So what do we get?
Minus i Hfi prime over
h bar, e to the i omega
fi plus omega t0, minus 1,
over omega fi plus omega.
You can imagine that
e to the i omega
t integrates to e to the
i omega t over omega.
So that's why that works.
And the two limits are t0 and 0.
Plus e to the i omega fi
minus omega t0, minus 1
again, over omega
fi minus omega.
Great.
Our integral is there.
It's done.
And now it's time to
appreciate what it tells us,
because it tells us something
very important, this formula.
So you look at this
and you say, well, OK.
This is the transition
amplitude to state omega--
I'm sorry-- state
f, final state.
And it depends on omega fi.
And omega fi just Ef
minus Ei over h bar.
So if I know my final
discrete state Ef,
I can figure out what is
the transition probability.
Now, these denominators are
intriguing because maybe
if you adjust the
frequency omega--
suppose you have an initial
state and a final state here.
You may adjust the frequency
omega to match them,
and in that case maybe make
the denominators equal to 0.
And that's exactly what
kind of happens here.
So, first of all, if you
look at this expression,
it's a sum of two terms that are
added together and multiplied
by a constant.
As t0 really goes
to 0, completely
goes to 0, t0, each
factor, actually,
if you see the Taylor
expansion of the exponential,
you cancel the 1 and you
then cancel the linear term
with the denominator.
This is just i t0.
And this is also i t0.
So they're comparable as
time is really going to 0.
But time going to 0 is
never of interest for us.
For us, we need to be
the time a little big
already so that
our calculations,
as we did in the constant
transitions that had lobes that
decreases constants over t0--
we needed the time to
be sufficiently large
so that the lobes are narrow.
And that, we could guarantee.
So t0 going to 0 is
not very interesting.
We need t0 a little bigger.
Not too big that the
rate of a process
overwhelms the probability.
But we need a little big.
So, in that case,
the numerators are
going to be bounded numbers.
You see, you have an
exponential minus 1.
So that varies from--
the magnitude of this thing
varies from 2 to 0, basically.
In fact, in these
numerators, you
can see, if the phase is 0
for some particular value--
if the exponential has a phase
that's proportional to 2 pi,
this is 0.
And then sometimes this
exponential is minus 1,
so it gets to minus 2.
So it's finite.
And the same is here.
So these are bounded numerators.
On the other hand, you
may have the possibility
that these things become 0.
And those are the cases
that are of interest to us,
the cases when those
terms are going to be 0.